okay everybody hear me okay great uh
yeah
very first thing you can get all the
slides for this right now on Seth Samuel
github IO if you want to follow along if
you can't see if you have accessibility
issues the there's a couple demos that
won't work quite right on mobile but if
you runs that any other problems please
let me know after so I can improve it
moving forward all right
my name is Seth Samuel new york portland
various other places portland back to
new york i can never move again without
ruining the symmetry of my life and just
driving myself crazy i am here to talk
about arbitrary computation on the GPU
with WebGL which is a really convoluted
way of saying we're gonna take WebGL
which does cool graphics stuff and we're
gonna make it do weird stuff for fun and
not so much profit but fun and it is
heart WebGL because I was testing
Unicode and emoji and all of that and I
finally got it working and I do heart
WebGL so it stayed that way
I'm south of Samuel on Twitter and said
Samuel on github one last piece of
boilerplate this is a talk that goes
pretty far into the weeds if you don't
know the idiom it means I'm gonna talk
about a lot of things really fast and
most of them are pretty far outside the
normal developer life if I lose you I'm
sorry it's totally my fault please come
up afterwards ask me questions on
Twitter and real life hopefully everyone
can still get something out of this talk
even though it is pretty weedy all right
what's WebGL WebGL is a JavaScript API
that lets us as web developers talk to
the graphics card using an API that's
very much like OpenGL what that means is
we can run graphics in about the closest
way to the metal that you'll ever get as
a web developer web assembly maybe down
the line will get you just as close but
right now WebGL is the best way to run
things really fast so what this looks
like is there's a nice little browser
sandbox we write JavaScript the
JavaScript gets piped to WebGL WebGL
talks off to the operating system and
the graphics card and then the graphics
card draws your graphics back onto an
HTML canvas which you can then talk to
you like any other HTML canvas one thing
to note all these arrows here are
one-way except for the canvas arrow
which we'll get to why that's important
so the basic structure of OpenGL is
something called shaders it's one of
many question
Cley Church Isis made inside of WebGL
but we're just gonna go with it we
inherited it from OpenGL who probably
made the decision while drunk it's
basically a functional pipeline you put
in data that data goes through a vertex
shader the vertex shader takes your data
and maps it to 3d points in space so
typically your data is going to look
something like a series of coordinates
that look a lot like 3d coordinates but
it doesn't have to it can be anything
you want to pipe in the vertex shader
hands that information off to the
fragment shader the fragment shader is
the only one here that sort of makes
sense with the word shader because it
shades color onto a fragment of your
graphics and then graphics happens so
here's a very simple snippet of what's
called GLSL the JIT the OpenGL shader
language which we use in WebGL as well
and because this is a weird descendant
of C JavaScript is a weird descendant of
C as well but this one's a weirder
descendant of C the way you actually say
what color your your pixel is going to
be is you set a global variable called
GL frag color equal to a vet for which
is just a fancy way of saying in RGB a
tuple so we're going to get past this V
cord thing which is the vertex shader
telling us where we are in space and
we're going to set the red to be s which
is the same as X and T which is the same
as Y because again nomenclature and
we're just gonna leave blue out and make
it fully not transparent so this is
actually WebGL this is all the demos in
here alive if you want to go see the
source go check out github and now we've
got our gradient so you can see in the
upper left where we're at zero zero it's
all black on the lower right red plus
green
equals yellow as we all learned in
kindergarten and in the top right red
bottom left green and what's really cool
here is all of this is happening at once
so it's not like WebGL is stepping
through every single piece of this
gradient and calculating it order the
graphics card is actually actually
calculating all of these colors at the
same time so we can use this to do some
really cool things so the edge finder
for those who don't know an edge finder
is exactly what it sounds like if you
have some image and you want to find
edges inside of it that is sort of what
we would think of as the outline
of objects what you can do is basically
you pass in a texture that's what we
call images and then you use a sampler
to get a pixel from it and so we're
gonna do the same thing where we're
gonna look at a pixel we're gonna look a
little bit to the left with that minus
0.005 and then we're gonna have some
threshold that tells us whether or not
this is an edge and if it's an edge
we're going to paint bright pink if
we're if it's not we're just gonna paint
black so here is a small child
attempting to eat an entire block of
cheese this is not my small child but if
I did have a small child she would also
probably try to eat an entire block of
cheese cuz cheese is delicious and here
we have her in edge format so you can
see I have this nice little slider here
that threshold that we saw earlier
I can decrease the threshold which means
basically everything looks like an edge
or I can make it really high which means
nothing looks like an edge and I can
sort of go through here and this is all
happening at liquid smooth 60 frames per
second and depending on the size of your
image that's not the case if you're
doing this in JavaScript you can do this
in JavaScript to some extent but you're
probably not going to be able to do
large images and be able to do all this
for exactly the same reason as before
which is that every single one of these
pixels is being considered at the same
time and last it's not a WebGL talk
without a particles demo particles are
cool here we're using GL position
instead of GL frag color which is the
equivalent version for the vertex shader
which basically says take some data and
swirl it around you see a sign you see a
cosign you know you're talking about
something swirly hey so we got one pixel
is that even visible no not really
okay well that's some more I can see it
on my screen there we go some of them
are showing up now we're up to sixth and
this is gonna take forever and I have to
finish on time they said there we go 200
more more more more there we go there's
a hundred thousand this is about word so
I'm still going at about 60 frames per
second here on my little MacBook Air
that is slowly trying to rise from the
podium on my power book at work I was
trying this out I could get over a
million pixels going before it started
to even budge yeah that's
pretty pretty bad but still better than
if you tried to do a million pixels in
JavaScript so why is it so powerful you
probably guess because I've said it like
five times because WebGL lets us pass
data off to the graphics card it can do
all of this math at once so you have two
main engine inside your computer you
have a CPU which is your something
processing unit I'm gonna say central
but I think I'm wrong someone tweeted me
that I'm completely wrong about that I
am oh yes I'd like being right which is
a general purpose tool it can do lots of
things and it can do them pretty well
but not as well as a specialized tool
your GPU your graphics processing unit
is a specialized tool what it does is
takes lots of small operation and does
them in parallel this tweet was
remarkably fortuitously time it came out
just like a week before when I was
getting the slides ready suppose you
wanted to do thousands of
kindergarteners math homework at the
same time on the GPU and that's exactly
what we want to do is lots of little
simple math operations but all at once
so someone noticed wait a second we
could do something beyond graphics here
it happens that graphics can generally
be represented as lots of parallel small
math operations but there's other things
that are lots of small math operations
all at once there's lots of things we do
in in research in math in you know all
sorts of regions where that's useful so
this sort of construct of the data
pipelines that's meant to draw graphics
is not ideal if you just want to get
down to the actual math and so they came
up with OpenCL as a complement to OpenGL
and so if OpenGL lets the WebGL lets us
do OpenGL on the web what lets us do
OpenCL on the web it's web CL and it's
coming soon it's never it's never coming
we're it's been coming soon for a very
long time and it doesn't seem like it's
ever gonna get here because the the
specs and the standards for the other
side of things have evolved past where
it is there's compute shaders which is
an even more ridiculous stretching of
the shaders nomenclature it's also
coming soon for a while there it was
kind of looking like it might actually
come soon and now it's looking like it's
probably gonna be replaced by something
else also but we might get to continue
traders so we're developers we like
building things if they don't give us
the tools we
them ourselves so how could we do this
well we can get data in right let's
really good at that already we can do
the math but we have to get it out so is
there a way there is a way and it's
pixels in fact it's the only way but
thankfully that two-way arrow with the
canvas means that we can pull data out
of it in a basically serialized pixel
format which is just numbers and that's
all we need for math there are a few
implementation challenges there's lots
of little niggly things as far as
getting all this to work smoothly but
there is one that is not work around a
bowl and that's serialization it takes
time and effort to get data into the
WebGL framework and it takes even more
to get it out of the canvas in fact it's
incredibly slow to pull pixels from a
canvas nan anyway you'd probably notice
in normal web operations but if you're
trying to lots and lots of pixels in and
pixels out it adds up really fast and so
we come to an example that actually
works
matrix multiplication for those who
don't know or who have not taken when
your algebra since many years ago like
me and had to go pull out the definition
of matrix multiplication for this demo
this is matrix multiplication so it's
just a fancy way of saying a matrix is
just a table of data multiplication is
exactly like it is with normal numbers
but we're gonna define it on two
different tables of numbers these column
and row highlights are not done with
that horrible CSS hack but I am gonna go
back and edit them so that they are in
the future cuz that was cool and weird
so yeah good you can see so that
highlight the top left cell is going to
be the sum of the product of the first
row of the left and the first column on
the right so if this example will be one
times nine plus two times four
the only way I've ever had this
explained to me that makes sense is you
take the left one you rotate it and then
you slide it through if you are not a
spatial learner that is absolutely no
use to do and I'm sorry there are a lot
of resources on the web to try and
explain it in different ways and
hopefully one of them will make sense
for you there so you can see that bottom
left notice the bottom row and so on and
so on basically we're just doing a lot
of kindergartners math all right
and you can see that we're basically in
a pass in the two input matrices as
images because of reasons and we're
going to iterate through for each
product cell we're gonna iterate through
the row of 1 and the column of the other
do a bunch of math and output it as a
color it turns out a color is nothing
more than four bytes and you can fit two
decent number of numbers into four bytes
all right so it's demo time all right so
here's our 2x2 again so this should be 1
times 5 plus 5 times 5 which is 30 yeah
yeah it's 30 good I succeeded in
kindergartners math homework so you can
see that that's but one times zero plus
five times eight that's 40 it's so on
its own all right so that's 2 by 2 and
now let's do it on the GPU and it's the
same which is good it's really bad when
you're trying to make a new
implementation and it doesn't agree with
the one that you know is right so it's
correct but it's really slow right we
got point 4 milliseconds on the Left 28
on the right that's a lot more that's
like 60 times slower which is really bad
so let's try this with the 3 by 3
all right that's still really fast on
the CPU not so fast on the GPU and all
right let's let's try bigger let's go up
to 64 I'm showing a 3 by 3 slice here
because I don't want to show 64 by 64
columns and rows on the slide 4 times
cuz no one could read anything just
gonna have to trust me that's they're
all here at 4 to 6 all right what sort
of actually we're faster now in the GPU
by a little bit there's a lot of noise
down at this side so I'm never sure if
this one's gonna come out this way uh
all right let's just go all the way so
this is a 1024 by 2024 matrix we were
gonna be multiplying so that's a million
elements in each matrix that's a lot of
math alright and now we sit around for
about three minutes but I will keep
talking to you because otherwise would
be really boring so this is where I just
talked about random things today let's
talk about so a little spinner in the
middle is just a little div it's got you
know
width and height its position absolutely
and there's a CSS transform as you
probably heard today if you didn't
already know is CSS transference happen
on the GPU which is great right now I'm
not gonna open dev tools because I don't
want to risk hosing this and having to
do this all over again
we're just hammering the CPU the
JavaScript implementation of this
multiplication is just iterating through
math and math and math and math and the
whole thing here is basically
unresponsive but that spinner is still
spinning and you'd think oh that's cool
it's because it's Hardware accelerate
it's on the GPU and it's really great
and that's true except to actually get
this spinner going you have to do work
on the CPU so if I started tried to
start calculating the CPU version of the
matrix multiplication and start that
spinning at exactly the same time it
wouldn't work because the CPU will get
locked up before the browser has a
chance to add the class to the spinner
which enables it renders it and ships it
off to the GPU to spin so that was a fun
little lesson here another interesting
lesson is that whatever is doing that
spinning whatever timer that's doing all
of that is not on the main thread
because it's still spinning right now so
even though the rendering is being done
on the GPU something has to tell the GPU
ok now it's time to tick that there's no
time built into most GPU framework so
something is firing off saying keep
spinning that and it's not doing it on
the main thread and that's cool if
you're really big nerd like me uh let's
see I forgot to start my timer I'm just
gonna have to keep talking about
anything what else do we have to talk
about here I hope it hasn't actually
popped up the little warning usually it
does my computer's to be feeling very
kind to me today or it's not doing any
work at all and I'm just gonna sit here
making things up until I run out of time
and they like take the cane to pull me
off the stage usually it pops up the
little you're the thread on tab whatever
this tab is called has become
unresponsive do you want to interrupt it
and it turns out if you don't click that
thing it's still doing work on the
background so that little pop-up thing
is really just a courtesy chance to get
you to kill it it doesn't it isn't no
way stopping the completely
out of control JavaScript execution
which is going on right now which is
kind of cool and still really hope this
works
I'll just keep waiting it's probably
working see last time I did this I
talked too long and actually to stop
talking about random things well when
that the answer came up this time of
course I completely ran out of things to
talk about way too early you have to you
know prepare material next time let's do
that oh yeah what about the what is the
local sports team here in Iceland other
fun things that learned about while
working on this project oh here's
another fun thing the way this is
working
it's just hung for a second the way this
is working is basically GPU shader code
gets all compiled and shipped off to the
WebGL oh yeah all right whoo okay 200
and we're into the range of benchmarking
here where milliseconds it's kind of a
goofy thing to be measuring this in but
that is 200 let's it's three and a half
minutes that's a really really long time
as a benchmark that's that's the sort of
thing where it's like why are you in
benchmarking this this is silly all
right let's do the GPU I guess I guess
you get another story ready just in case
nope we're fine so that's faster that's
about well that the GPU is a little slow
today which makes its math earlier
easier so that's about 200 something
times faster that's that's better
that's that's way better all right cool
so why well all right this is big no
notation and I promise that's the last
really Matthew thing in the talk
basically to calculate an N by n matrix
that's a million times a million and
then for every one of those output cells
you have to go through a row in a column
so that's n cubed if n is the width of
the matrix because we can do every
single output cell at once on the GPU
we can be finished in n the earlier edge
finder is N squared if you do it because
you have to step through every pixel and
it's constant time on the GPU which is
constant time it's awesome
alright so for those who don't have like
a visceral understanding what those
those numbers mean and you got the
bottom line and squared is the purple
one a constant is a constant and n cubed
is the biggest so this is N equals zero
to five so this is like those first two
examples we did here there and already n
cubed is just running away from zero to
ten around a hundred we can't even see N
anymore and N squared is looking pretty
n ish and yeah 1024 which we just did
you can't even see so the lower lines
there because n cube just gets so big so
fast so that's why we get so much gain
from doing all these things in parallel
all right this is awesome we've got a
working proof of concept we've shown 200
X speed gains this is amazing let's go
do really cool stuff with this alright
we can do hash collision are you a white
hat hacker you can make sure your
passwords are secure you a black hat
hacker you can crack people's hat
passwords we can do Bitcoin mine
basically all Bitcoin mining happens on
the GPU in fact the original thought
process that went into this talk was
gonna be cool to have a distributed
website where people could pay their way
not through micro transactions or
anything like that but just by crunching
bitcoins for the site owner it's a nice
little background payment system and
they wouldn't have to install anything
just drop a script and would run but you
want to be able to do it on the GPU
because that's how you do a Bitcoin
mining media encoding a lot of media
encoding you can do really fast if you
can paralyze it break it up into chunks
and then you encode it machine learning
is basically again just a lot of
kindergarteners doing math which you
know in all senses of the words signal
analysis and process this is a little
cheating because audio is really just
the same as video it's all just media
but it's kind of different cuz it's
sound alright protein folding you might
notice some of these are sounding really
familiar they sound a lot like things
you can download screen savers for
because these are highly chunk able
parallelizable tasks that benefit a lot
from running on the graphics card
alright actual application this this is
the big payoff nope can't do hash
collision can't do Bitcoin mining can't
do media encoding
you might be able to machine-learning
signal analysis and protein folding I'm
intrigued by possibly getting these to
work but the first three big obvious
things you could do here no all right
why this is not my cat if I had I do
have a cat she would get into this
trouble if I had blinds which I don't so
the only thing saving this room being my
cat is I don't actually have blinds like
that
all right this is the big one there are
no bit operations in the current version
of the shader language server it's
supplied by WebGL you need bit
operations for basically anything you
want to do with a fancy algorithm very
very smart people have spent the last 40
or 50 years coming up with really good
ways to do things with bits because all
our computers run on bits so if you
design your algorithm using bit
operations you can usually optimize them
really well and we don't have any of
those that's why we can't do hashes we
can't do Bitcoin mining which is
basically just hashes can't do any of
the other fun stuff boo unresponsive
window so if you paid really close
attention you might have seen the
spinner actually freezes a little bit
during the WebGL version and the reason
is because if you're hammering your
graphics card having it do nothing but
kindergartener math then it can't do
anything else like draw your window as
it changes it's it's the the normal
problem we have as JavaScript developers
is Oh get it onto the GPU so that it's
not hogging up the main thread here we
put too much stuff on the GPU and you've
lost everything again and oh it's level
time as this is a fun little landmine it
turns out different operating systems
have different thresholds at which they
will say no your shaders been running
too long it's time for you to just stop
and there's no error there's no
guaranteed return state sometimes it'll
give you something sometimes it'll just
return a blank pixel and you just hit
these completely without any warning and
it's terrible when you're trying to
figure out why your code doesn't work
all right what do we need to make it
work this is a big one it's super easy
we're probably not going to get it but I
can still hope in newer versions of the
shader language in OpenGL have bit
operations a bunch of other cool stuff
and if they just implemented them in
WebGL we'd have all of that but there's
a new graphic standard coming out
there's a few new graphic standard
coming out one is Vulcan there's also
apples metal and there's always been
Microsoft's direct3d
and it seems more likely that we'll get
a web version of one of those than a
increase in web GL but I can always hope
canvas WebGL in the web worker Mozilla I
believe has this implemented last time I
checked they were announcing it and I
believe it works now so this is great
this means that you can take all of this
work and the serialization and all of
that which does hog up the main thread
you can push it off in a web worker and
it will get all of that off for you all
right let me sum up WebGL is awesome
graphics are fun we can do really crazy
things if we want to try and push it
really far and with a little bit of help
we could actually make this into
practical applications that's it thanks
[Applause]